Sau thông tin lên quan tới vụ việc ma chăm tính thiết lợt mạnh, nhiều trân học tại Hanoi đồng loạt
phát đi thông báo về một gốc thực phẩm giám chấn an phủ hình.
Những ngày gần đây, không biết phủ hình bài tỏ tâm lý bất an, đặc biệt với bữa ăn bán chú của
học sinh sau khi con ngàn Hanoi thông tin lên quan tới vụ việc dết mổ.
Tíu thu ma chăm tính thiết lợt mắt dịch tả lợt châu viên.
Cung cấp cho các trợ và công ty trách nhiệm nghe hạnh thực phẩm gần phát, để cung cất thực phẩm trong một số trân học trên diễm bán.
Sau khi hình hình hình hình hình bạnh, là hysz tữ triner l权 là ngình,
bình hình hình hình hình thử tần 3D vụ l接下來 của quán định.
Vậy tìm ra lãm v Sec phần, hình hình hình hình hình hình hình, hình hình hình hình hình nâng, hình hình fân,
hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình, hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình thử bật.
Bà thơ kích chà để trung tuổi bien tập khi khräp."
Chức caplık từ giữa như trường đánh anh trong thông tin ở đơn vị cùng cấp xuất an và quy trình kiểm soát thức phẩm.
Dù các trường lý tục khẳng định của cung bảo đam, tâm lý phụ hình vẫn trường hoàn toàn được dài toàn.
Nhưng người cho rằng việc công khai dành sách nhà cung cấp là cần thiết, những quan trọng hơn,
là cơ quan trích năng sớm làm gió đường đi của thức phẩm cung bảo đam, để tránh lọt vào bữa ăn hoặc đường.